it's Monday March 2nd wash your [ __ ]
grab your balls and salute the flag
[ __ ] the Church of what's
happening now is brought to you by
manscape I know the winter blues has got
some of you down but you don't leave the
house the weeds have grown back in and
your song smells like 15 that Iranians
but the spring is coming if you want to
feel like it's Spring Break 1988 again
you gotta get manscaping let me tell you
some manscape is tremendous I've been
telling you this for months it's your
time you know you got a bush down there
it smells like a Greek - that's not seek
you have a gyro that's what happens when
you have all that bush you want
something to go down and embarrass
yourself go to manscape calm right now
let's cut it out they got the lawnmower
3.0 that is what I'm talking about now
do me a favor get 20% off and free
shipping when you go to manscape dot-com
slash Church CH you are CH that's
manscape calm slash Church for 20% off
your first daughter get manscape get
lazy and become a human being again
let's get this party started
it's March the 2nd you understand me
it's a brand new day a brand new week
and a brand new month tell me it doesn't
feel like Christmas was yesterday it
does it feels like Christmas was two
days ago and it's March 2nd number one I
want to thank everybody who came out to
the show in Vegas Friday night thank you
very much for supporting us Dean Delray
and Freddie Korea were great
Freddie Quran didn't disappoint in Dean
Delray and it's weird how I Freddie you
know you Duke I had a weird
I just turned 57 guys so for a week I
was walking on clouds you know I think
you could have felt that if he wants to
podcast maybe you could for a week I was
walking on a client's not because I was
happy I was trying to 57 but because I
couldn't believe I made it to 57 and the
funniest thing about that is that now
what I didn't see happen to me I'm
watching in front of me happened to kids
till I met 10 years ago on a joke and
had a one-man show huh and I want to
open my core I met them at the improv
doing a spinal or in Santa Barbara or I
like I met Freddie in Reno seven years
ago was something he opened for me or
something and then he we talked a little
bit and he wanted to further his career
and he moved to Vegas and he chases it
he's got a house and a wife and a day
job he started a job no yeah you know I
mean this guy chases it so when you
watch people grow it's a and you're
growing at the same time it's kind of
weird to kind of you you're like man I'm
getting old
me and Freddie worked seven years ago
six years ago in Reno five-year whatever
the hell it was
it's so weird our for a week I was I
wouldn't listen birthdays I don't care
about birthdays I stopped caring my
birthday's and I was 13 all right
it was just uh it's the truth I could
care less people having birthday parties
and you know
let's meet me at a restaurant at 7:30
you know are you crazy
it's Wednesday I got time to meet at
7:30 cuz cuz you're turning 50 I'm not
one of those people you care less but uh
it was just weird that that that for
some reason I never thought I'd make it
past 50 and now I'm 57 years old and and
you know I haven't had my god what do
you call that a men at 50 mm crisis a
midlife crisis the only midlife crisis
I've had is watching you people with
your expressions on your faces when I'm
up on stage last night I had a spotty
source a late night I had a follow Benji
ruffle or whatever his name is who I
think is hilarious and you know I don't
think they were prepared for me it was
so weird how they were not prepared for
me I was in a weird spot in the lineup I
had him put me up at a 45 which is like
you know it was just too early for me
like a four you know like Dracula don't
come out till midnight like that's I
like I'm safe after 9:45 at the store
8:45 there's still a little ripe for me
and I went up there and I wanted to try
new jokes and good and I do the best set
of my life
but I imposed my will like I let it be
known that I was in the room they didn't
really take the Rakhi with me too much
not the way home I felt happy like I was
like oh my god because it's tough to
understand what the mindset was what
mitzi sure I don't get messy sure enough
credit all the time because I didn't
realize the power Mitzi shore till after
I taped my Netflix special I heard
everything she told me throughout the
years in my [ __ ] head I'm gonna tell
you guys a funny story that a lot of
people don't know that me and Ari were
talking about Sunday morning do you know
that in like 1995 shoot through the
industry out of there what do you mean
how could she told the industry to take
a hike so any agent so you understand
like people at home and fill in the
stamina think about if you have people
who control you at work you know how
like you have bosses if you work in a
cubicle or you're a plumber or whatever
the hell you are you have a boss and
then he has bosses right like she would
let those bosses on the jobsite like she
told them no cops for industry if you
want to get in here you pay like
everybody else
so it's shun the industry away from the
store so for years if you told an agent
or a manager you know I'm doing a
showcase come see me and they go to the
store they gonna when I gone down there
and they'd make up an excuse that they
have dinner at the improv do it at the
improv Harlem when it's at the improv
and that was because in 95 she threw him
out in 99 she threw him out again
because they were gonna do this show
called the night of a thousand windows
Dahmer era and all these people are
gonna come and they wanted to send
hundreds a hundred seats aside for the
industry and at 3:30 she said [ __ ] you
you're paying for tickets people were
livid like comics will cry and the whole
thing but that was Missy I asked the one
day I go why don't you want the end this
for you because she goes it creeps you
guys out like it does
she goes yeah creeps you guys out when I
shot the Netflix special I realized he
was right
it creeped me the [ __ ] out it creeped me
out when somebody when you feel somebody
has control over you like Ygritte
I don't know it's the weirdest feeling
you know I learned to get up on stage in
front of her that was horrible for me
that was horrible guys you have no idea
how horrible that was the hardest thing
you had to do in your life in those days
when you were on stage and you saw her
walked in and she sit down I would die I
would die right on stage it's like a
couple weeks ago Louie went down to San
Diego with his mom and they were having
a good night and Steve Simone was very
nice and he asked Lee to open up the
show and before this for the last three
weeks I have been laughing at this by
myself because I know I tell you guys
that if you're an accountant or a banker
once somebody comes to you in a problem
you've been doing it so long you could
figure it out you could tell them the
answer just but just from listening to
what they're telling you you know Lee
calls me up I how'd you do that Monday
night he had gone up at the Comedy Store
he did great I think it was a Tuesday or
Wednesday went to La Jolla and he said
did the same set but not the way up to
something happened on the way the dance
well he got to La Jolla already his mom
was in the audience he's ready to go up
on stage and the guy that's playing the
piano he's singing songs right now in La
Jolla and between you and me you want to
shoot yourself he's the nicest guy in
the world
I love the debt I've known him for 20
year 20 plus years
he's Vicki Barbara ex-husband please up
they're playing a piano oh that old
black magic got me and it's Mel and
after 20 minutes you want to shoot
yourself you're like why am i listen to
this Bob Mitch from music for so anyway
he plays the music he does a great job
with it he really does he's playing the
piano he's like a one-man band
they're going so while he brings his
guitar player friend who losing he
Street days from dying from cancer was
he down there that no no play the guitar
he's got a guitar friend that looks like
these three days away from the chemo
like he's done he just even the chemo
threw about they're like listen we can't
do that with you
this guy's a relic and he's up there I
can I'm gonna playing the electric
guitar you think you're in a dream you'd
come living in a dream this is not a hat
Lou Lou being a player the piano player
that's his name so it wasn't a little
messed up you know was yeah that's what
I thought you were saying was a good no
no the guy's name is Lou and he's and I
love Lulu years every time you saw Lou
you like Lou
so Lee's about the gone stage he's on
the side he's a high comedies thought
his heart is into it and also glucose
are you guys ready for a beautiful night
level and they clap yeah you know these
Simone's in the house let them hear it
again are you ready for a great night at
the Comedy Store
yeah coming to the stage mr. Lee SWAT
always ask him how he did and he goes I
don't know it sucks I didn't do good or
whatever this time it was like I bombed
but then as the story had Deeping us oh
the guy called my name wrong on the way
up for the stage right there I knew
exactly what happened he cracked him he
just sometimes he's crack as a comic
your name call the wrong and you can't
figure it out because you you already
went through with him 20 times what your
name was how do you pronounce that how
do you pronounce the how do you
pronounce that it looked at my name is
Joey Diaz you can't mess that up
yes you can go to Utah Montana Wyoming
you will hear dialects of my name that
you've never heard before a specialized
to those rooms and riverfront Wyoming
and all those
oh my god I'm a mother there's a Hindu
hotel that does comedy in Wyoming the
nicest family in the world the nice and
they run the whole town the whole town
smells funny
if you can't wait to get the hell out of
there was no late check-in like this day
state my friend you could stain your
like I gotta get out of here the smell
of your sandals give me a headache the
hotel got the coronavirus skin because
the smell the sand I don't even know
what I'm I smell like I don't mean I
don't think there was hummus then there
were nice people and I still remember
going up there and the guy brought me in
like daya's like I know I know this
story and you could sit with me for days
and go you know I thought about it I
really didn't crack what they listen
I've been there cuz I was doing comedy
at that time about four years and I had
never heard my name and I'm all fired
I'm about the beach and stuff I lost my
guy the Hindu brought you up by he he
was the house emcee and he was also the
hotel the the front desk clerk you have
no idea this is what people don't know
this is what people don't know and
you're sitting there going what and
there's a bunch of white people in the
room and he's up there and doing it up
this is not happening this cannot be
happening in my life why did I get into
comedy and Austin a guy called like just
thought my name like this man is name is
Joey
it's like disease I went up there and
just died a slow death I mean I ran
upstairs and packed my bags and I ran
the hell out of that hotel I was I'm
even spend the night oh no I drove like
I just like yeah I couldn't get over the
bombing and I couldn't get over the
smell and him kwame disease where did he
get disease diseases so people have no
idea how fear like you have to be so
cool to cover up your fear like I am
constantly I'm scared every like I was
scared in Vegas to the point
I was I was having the heart
palpitations in my room at 7 o'clock I
swear to God Friday night in Vegas guys
I was having the heart palpitations but
you know what that means that means I
can that's all that means that I really
care cuz I want to go up I know it's Las
Vegas
I know people bought plane tickets I
know people got rooms I know people
going to other shows I'm one of the many
things they're doing and I don't want to
let them down I swear to you guys Friday
I was a massive 7 o'clock
cuz the show started at 9:00 I couldn't
wait to get that but that show started I
took my heart was pounding so much I
didn't eat dinner
I took blood pressure medication and I
doubled up on an aspirin I'm like I'm
not gonna make it tonight Jesus I was
like I'm not gonna make it through
tonight this is too much so I got up
about I went in the shower I guess what
I did I walked around the hotel like to
put on the 28th and I walked the stairs
to the 29th floor no I walked downstairs
for the 27th floor and I just walked
around I didn't think about the set and
then I met security upstairs the core
design they're like were you coming from
you oh my god I was downstairs on loud
you know I was I was walking around the
lobby scared because if I went down I'd
see people right and they'd stop me
you're just walking around like the
hotel room area yeah like the room was
like a [ __ ] pizza like lobbying
Weinstein with a con you know I'm saying
oh my god I'm walking through the hotel
I went from the 28th floor to the 27th
floor to the 26th floor and then I
walked back up to the 28th floor and
that wasn't gonna kill me nothing was
because I hate stairs more than anything
in life Christ and me I [ __ ] hate
says I didn't take the elevator up I
forced myself to walk up the stairs and
my anxiety went away and then once I saw
Dean and the club manager in security
then we had another long walk and that
helped ease my nerves a little more it's
amazing how fear plays into my world
and how you know what you guys learned
the standards for years I try to teach
my daughter my daughter has a problem
around dogs guess who had the same
problem I did and I try to tell her that
people read fear people really read fear
I learned not enough I was always scared
till this damn scared but what I used to
walk around the Bronx when I was a 5
year old and a 6 year old I was
petrified like I was petrified I was
like a kidnapped I was petrified again
hit or somebody hit me with a car like I
was always scared of things that you
shouldn't be thinking about but the
thing I was scared of the most rooted
augs and I would react funny to dogs so
because of that fear the dogs
I always got bit and I couldn't and I
kept like I started getting bit by dogs
and I was around four and then went over
the age of eight how many times to get
bit I probably got bit without
exaggeration I've tried to count it I
got a bit on my face I got bit in the
leg once by a Doberman Pinscher I got
bit in the leg again by a dog at Sacred
Heart School for Boys that's not was
really scared of dogs he just came up to
me in those days you know and this is
how fearful I was a dog would see me
from 30 feet and he would feel my fear
and he would run up to me and bite me
that's how fearful I wasn't like the dog
would read my fear and just run up to be
and bite me so that's the type of fear I
had so somewhere along the line that at
an early age I had to learn how to
control my fear from within from inside
the heaven like my heart would beat and
I would get crazy and that dog would
read my fear and they come up to me in
my business I can't be I can't let the
audience know I'm scared you know by the
time I get there and I get involved and
I smoke that joint in the green room and
I talk to the club manager and I listen
to the guy in front of me don't comedy
then the field levels down a little bit
every every duh every show for me is
different how much fear gets into the
show and now at this point I welcome it
but Friday's fear was the worst I've had
since the night that I had a follow
Morgan Murphy at the store and I told
Pauly to go up in front of me and he
said why no because I'm having an
anxiety attack and he just looked at me
like I was having three heads and it
goes back to submit Seashore everything
we were talking about earlier but just
to the fear I had I had to contain it as
they had a young age and I still have
the same fear like you know then my
mother died and all this stuff happened
to me but you don't think I had fear
when I walked into that prison you don't
think I you know I've always had fear
and I've always learned how to control
it but I've always learned how to flip
like I've always learned how to flip it
into self confidence even though I don't
have any self confidence somebody gave
me [ __ ] like three weeks ago they sent
me like a Facebook thing they're like
why do you always post disgusting things
in the morning like sayings and stuff
and at first I got a little offended but
then I took the time I said I don't have
the time to explain to this guy why but
since he asked I should tell when I wake
up in the morning when I open my eyes
and I walked to take that first pee in
the morning I can't tell you I wake up
like I'm waking up in a world that like
the world got like we got a bomb dropped
on us the night before and I didn't know
when I wake up in the morning I wake up
very scared you know I remember when I
first went out into a real world how
scared I used to be like when I used to
have to go to work I'll have to fill out
job applications or I'd have to anything
in that realm I was petrified when I
first got into the real world like 16 17
and a half
once I started like getting a job not
delivering papers and all that stuff but
once I started like
once I lost the lumber job and I had to
go into the real world and do all that
stuff I used to be really fearful cuz I
had no self-confidence had no high
school diploma I had no no no college
education I didn't have anything and I'd
be really fearful and for me to make
myself go to those things or to go meet
people or to even do something like what
made me walk into Colorado Mountain
College when I was 18 years old with no
high school diploma and sign up for
classes and I lied on the application do
you have a high school diploma yeah yeah
yeah I didn't even check it out in the
eighties like what possessed me to go in
there cuz I was so fearful and I
wouldn't dog when I go to those places I
don't say a word like I don't say a word
like I'm not funny
I don't try to be funny I'm just happy
that I'm in there that my fear that I
overcame my fear to go into those places
but part of my point was from 18 to 25
even so on my thirties my early thirties
dog I used to have to say things to
myself define myself up and those things
are what I write in the morning those
things I write of the fire me up believe
it or not there to fire me the hell up
when I got up in the morning and I pee
and then I have my coffee and there's
something on my coffee I'm like I
already have fear about the spot I have
to do that night like that more at 8:30
in the morning I'm already fearful I'm
like oh my god I gotta go to the store
tonight oh my god I gotta fly that you
know Columbus tonight oh my god I
already have fear like this fear is in
me so I have to say something to myself
I'm not the type of guy to look in the
mirror I don't want to look at myself
and go you could do this so instead of
doing all that stupid stupid [ __ ] I
just say to myself as I'm going in the
shower like you know what somebody's
gonna have to suck my dick today like
plain and simple if I get up to go do
this somebody says suck my dick
somebody's got to pay me
somebody's gotta [ __ ] pay for this
[ __ ] I'm going out there to get my
[ __ ] lunch box
all those things I say to myself would
overcome the little [ __ ] fear ahead
that's the part of the problem the hard
part for me is I have fears but like I
don't like I I guess I don't know if
this is what it is but to me it seems
like like my self-esteem is so low that
a guy if someone else isn't motivating
me or if the thing isn't motivating me
me saying that stuff to me doesn't
motivate me I'm like Who am I to say
that like like I don't even believe
myself when I when I say that I don't
believe myself either but if it gets me
out the door right I don't believe
myself either guys but if it gets me out
the door that's all that matters if I
can lie to myself and convince myself
that something good is gonna happen and
gets me out the door I don't care about
anything else I just want to get out the
door that's a once I get at the door I
figure it out once I get there I'll
figure it out it's getting out that door
that used to scare me to death like a
people I know a lot of people who who
think because this is all it is it's a
thought that you'd like self-confidence
it's just a thought that comes to your
mind how do I know because I experienced
it for years
when I was a young kid I experienced it
I walk around my head now you know my
that that's no self-confidence you'd
walk around looking at the floor I
wouldn't look around then I got a
hitting that with a lunchbox and you
know I got beat up a few times i lady a
street and then you learn how to you get
self-confidence you you know people
always go oh you know you I don't have a
self-confidence to go up to women you
you can't you can't even think about it
women like aggressive men yeah they'll
tell you no but they want an aggressive
man what's aggressive that you go up to
and rip their shirt off no well that
Savage is here go up and talk to them go
up and say something that somebody else
wouldn't say you know they've already
heard all the lines right they've
already heard you know all the stupid
pick-up lines if they still exist I mean
no pickup lines exist I
how old I am I don't even know how to
pick up anybody you know whatever I pick
up line still exist I don't even know
but tell them something that they've
never heard before blow their mind with
something I'm not talking about going
over and trying to be Shakespeare or
trying to drop my some line from adores
movie or something
probably be yourself what do you have to
offer that person a ton in your head you
don't think so I don't think so so so
bless you till today I still sit there
and I'm like why do people come to my
shelves and it all goes back to who get
locked up and you know sleeping in a
rocketship it goes all back to those
feelings no because I go up there I put
my I don't know why I go up there and I
say things I normally wouldn't say in
front of people that's why you're paying
cuz I wouldn't say these things this is
somebody who's in that was taking all my
brain now this is why I am the person
who you want to hear you wouldn't pay 25
dollars to go see do you know saying
like the person that you want to know I
gotta be me I got to go up there be you
know so much has happened in the last 18
months that that's what excites me so
much in my life and I'm not talking
about accomplishments have had no cosmas
mister last day I'd have had one really
really good accomplishment
the breakthrough I had on my stand-up
comedy and it took me 25 years to
breakthrough what are you talking about
breakthrough what are you saying Joey
your ears what are you saying that what
I'm saying is I don't care about the
tickets sold
I don't care about the shows it's what I
do on stage that wouldn't matters if you
notice I don't sell shirts at shows I
don't want to do nothing at a show the
only thing I go to do when I come to
your city is to give you the best
possible show I could give you people
get mad at me when I go oh you know I
got this podcast and you just swing by
bro I didn't come to [ __ ] Cleveland
to do a [ __ ] podcast
I'm coming to Cleveland to do four shows
and all that's on my mind is [ __ ] you
[ __ ] up will I'd [ __ ] you up
all four shows I don't know I don't know
but I'll tell you what I'm going out
there in the back of my mind - [ __ ] you
guys up because it doesn't matter
I pulled the way the safety net the
safety net disappeared three years ago I
think after I shut the net first thing
all that stuff went away because
everything Mitzi sure had taught me
since 1997 to 2004 came back to me and
that era and since then I've lived on
what she taught me those blast those
seven years of seeing her every Sunday
every other Sunday you know every third
Sunday I'd see her and she'd make a note
about my stand-up but she drop a gem on
me and you know what I didn't believe in
a lot of her gems today everything I do
is based off her teachings to me and
stand up everything I do no more
thinking about what I know I went back
to her school of thought which was to be
an animal on stage you're not performing
for them you're performing for you
you're going up there and knocked it out
of the park don't give them what they
want give them what you want and explain
to them why it's funny
explain to them how it crashes and
collides with your world that's all that
matters to me I don't want to sell CDs
after a show I don't want to sell
t-shirts I don't want to go to the rock
and roll music I come to your town to
[ __ ] you up for those four shows that's
all I'm focused on in the daytime I go
to if you know whatever one of your
restaurants whatever you have to offer
that's something different I try my
hardest always to go to one of those
places but at the same time my focus is
on resting so I am prepared to give you
a hundred percent and that's how I
remember her telling me what do you do
on game shows how I go do this and she's
like you relax when you do a show that
night I want you to collect your
thoughts when it's a big show
but when you come here you're coming
here to work out she goes I want you to
be off-the-cuff more when you come down
here or say your jokes but I want you to
say I'm out of order
force yourself to say I'm out of order
so you're always working about a
different level like sometimes you're
open it would be your closer just she
always taught me that stuff and I
wouldn't have confidence in doing it but
I'd listen to her I do it and it would
work and I see myself now I've been
saying this for months on the podcast
early to whatever because I see it I
know what has to be done
those little bar rooms that we hate as
comics or all those little [ __ ] rooms
that we hear this comics they have to be
done and you'll feel them not now but
you'll feel the difference in 20 years
when you're at one of the three major
clubs when you're at the Comedy Cellar
in New York when you're on stage and
you're controlling the audience like
Moses made the red part see you'll see
you're not gonna think about your house
or your car or your family when you're
on stage you're thinking about what gave
you the ability to part that ocean like
that to make people laugh you know a
couple of weeks ago or two or three
months ago you went into the show with
hastens trail and you came back and you
were very very very impressed you were
very impressive what he had done
yeah and I said to you that it's it's
it's a it's a thing that goes off in
your head you know my daughter mercy
goes to bully Busters she goes to and I
look at the kids in that and every week
I've been looking at these kids for the
last 18 months every Monday and
Wednesday and Friday I'm there my
daughter I'm there without Fridays I'm
not there if I'm out of town but
obviously if she's got a class I'm
pretty much there watching it and I
don't you know I go to watch her not to
be a fighter or whatever I just go there
to watch of the supporter I'm not one of
those parents that's gonna drop your kid
off and go run errands I don't go there
I don't get on the phone when I take her
there my attention is on her
and I look at the other kids on what
they're doing and it's so weird how I
can tell the kids that have it and even
though they don't have it today they got
something I'm gonna I could tell you
that someday the switch is gonna turn
there's a little boy in there
with glasses it's a cute little kid for
the 11 months that kid messed up coach
call him up and say do this technique
and he would do it and mess it up but I
could tell on the walk back to his seat
how sad he was that he got it wrong I
would watch this kid and I see how sad
it is how sad it was that he got it
wrong and when the coach calling and he
tried again and this time it be 50% on
and 50% off and he wouldn't have it but
I could tell on the walk back to his
chair whether he was happy or depend
there's another little boy in the class
a little boy would always beat him and
that would eat him alive I would see if
I would eat him alive and I remember one
day touching his head you know cuz his
mom is nice his mom just had another
baby and I remember just touching his
head and Tom one day this isn't a click
and you're gonna become a savage well
guess what it clicked they took like 16
months for this kid for it to click he
is a savage now he's little boy now
there's no little boy in that class
that's like floor he just turned 4 he's
the most beautiful little boy you've
ever seen in your life this little kid
throws little wheat punches a little
[ __ ] cakes but I'm telling you right
now that kid's gonna be a killer in ten
years why because he's gonna put it
together you could always tell the
people and they're gonna put it together
it's not gonna happen for you overnight
and this happened listen how do I know
because I still remember starting comedy
in 91 and in 96 seeing people more
comics would talk to me
and the word on the street was and then
it was Doug Stanhope who told me the
story I bumped into Doug Stanhope in 96
and Seattle 97 one of those Jesus now I
think it was 90 it was New Year's 96 so
it was the summer of 96 I bumped into
this Doug Stanhope and he immediately
remembered me and he started talking to
me I had had a brief encounter with
Stanhope in 91 at the broker listen to
the years I'm telling you guys it's 2020
in 91 I met Doug Stanhope when I was
maybe into comedy maybe eight or nine
months and then Stanhope came back maybe
a year later and he came back as a
headliner and now I was doing comedy
maybe eighteen months and he stayed all
my house I invited him to stay over the
house and I was divorced and they had a
night off
comics always had that week suck that
was a triple one that sucked because
Tuesday was Boulder Wednesday you had
off but Thursday you had Craig Friday
you had webelo and Saturday you had
Colorado Springs or something don't
quote me on this but there was always
that Wednesday night off if the comic
was cool on Tuesday night any of the two
comics I'd say what are you guys doing
tomorrow and no ain't nothing find the
cheap hotel don't worry about it just
stay at my house so I would open up my
house today about tons of comics you
know I remember summer I remember some I
don't remember some of them are dead
some of them are on the business some of
them you know whatever but a lot of guys
used to spend the night on my house if
they were cool you know and they would
help me to like they would give me leads
from they were from or whatever you know
it was a two-way street I was learning
about the business I was asking them
questions and they would give me answers
so they got to get they got to stay for
free and
got to ask him a stupid questions all
night about calmly how do you get good
one of the Booker's what's my next move
you know and I'm never meeting Stanhope
and let's say in two or three years I
think I was at the broker for maybe two
years no time we did family every week
except maybe the Christmas break I don't
think so I think we even didn't New
Year's there something cuz I remember
going while I'm doing comedy two years
and I'm doing my first New Year's a
people like you won't do New Year's to
fight five years and I'm like look at me
doing New Year's my second year in the
business oh so you think of all those
comics I had a I had a two-bedroom condo
on a couch downstairs so I would invite
them to stay over so when I bumped into
Stanhope years later five or six years
later I remember getting off stage when
9m getting off stage because we worked
together New Year's 97 and when he got
offstage cuz I heard a nasty rumor about
you oh my god here and I kidnapped
somebody or that I went to prison at
that time I didn't really talk about
that type of stuff I was still very
embarrassed about it and I go what did
you hear and he goes the word on the
street is the host from the broker got
really funny Wow and I go really who
told you that in English that's and
everybody's saying on those Tribble ones
that the hosts from the broker got
really funny over the years like when I
was at the broker that I didn't have a
chance like I tried I didn't have a
chance
I still remember coming out with cups
I'm Madonna did a book table book 1991
or 92 it was 92 Madonna did like Vogue
video and either some some some
something that she did have like cones
I still remember coming out to vogue
with two cups on my tits I thought that
was funny
so please guys have patience and support
your local open
that's why I open mics because your
support in the future
somebody must can you imagine that until
this day I still think about that and I
want to take my car crashes and I came
out to vote how many times did you do it
all you need to do that mistake is once
that's okay you think that's funny and
do it twice shame on ya good thing is I
did it one time I came out the vogue and
I would spin the cups around and then
make believe I was dancing it was
horrible ly it was horrible and then
when I got the Seattle do you know I get
my fourth year and I used to do this
Spanish comedy show you know I think
Josh wolf still has pictures a girl
would come off stage and play the
maracas and I would do comedy no oh
please
in between your jokes it was like spoken
words not she play the maracas when I
was up on stage Oh No
yeah I called it like salsa comedy and I
wore like a ruffled tuxedo puffy shirt
yet and I like the shirt would they
could we're going to a wedding like that
type of stuff I mean guys you're not
gonna come to me with no story about
nothing I've done it all
I've walked out there's no bigger loser
than me I have done it all
you know I said just remember that cuz I
found like the yeah
I know a girl that has all that stuff I
know a girl that one day she's gonna
sell that stuff I'm making a ton of
money
oh she's got all the pictures of that my
ex-girlfriend I'm you in the shirt and
the shirt of her on stage playing the
maracas with white dress on I hope that
if you went to those shows you never
told people about it or if you did see
those shows in 96 and 95 in Seattle you
just stop thinking about it you just got
out of your mind
cuz I dunk it there's what I gonna tell
you listen we all have something we want
to do and there's a price to pay and the
price is to put in the work and make a
ton of mistakes and get called a fool
and some way another breaking out
just you know I go on here forever but
at least you try me and in some way
that's a good thing at least you have
the balls to try it because all your all
your goal was just to be funny you like
it when I call was just become a decent
human being man
my goal was I've been such a stiff for
so long in 1995 at the age of 33 I had
just gone through so much you know and I
was sick and tired I knew what I would
wanted to do and I knew what I didn't
want to do and I said you know what I
don't know anything to anybody I don't
have parents I don't have to impress
anybody I don't have to get a college
degree I don't have to do anything how
do I make myself happy how do I make
myself productive how do I make myself a
good person like what could I do to stop
stealing what can I do to stop this drug
abuse what can I do that stop the way
you know for God's sake I tried to rob
somebody and I hadn't been doing it
fears what can I do to avoid all this
you know the only thing I could do and
divide myself into it without thinking
twice about it was calmly guys I hated
working I hated working I hated arguing
you buy money I hated all that stuff but
when you're a laborer you have no leg to
stand on when you don't know about some
you have to know like to stand on and
you have to pay your price before people
pay you in society and I got it I just
didn't want to do it I kind understood
that that's fine that doesn't work for
me I want you to make me vice-president
a company today and I'll keep working on
it but I knew I was never gonna be
satisfied even if they gave me that
because I had had that I had had a bunch
of trouble I had talked myself into
great jobs that after a month of being
am like this is great but it's not what
I want to do like this is a great
salesman's job this is a cush salesman's
job or whatever but this is not
what I want to do I did that 20 times Li
I think that 20 times I almost talked
myself into being a rep for a
pharmaceutical company with no college
degree one of them Boulder how just a
fake resume oh Jesus I thought all I
knew is if I get myself into the room I
could talk that guy into giving me the
job that's what I did no you understand
me that's what I knew but I still
remember going to the interview and the
guy asked me about what I studied me
that you know that's why I asked you do
people when you go to you know come in
this and you went to editing jobs
interviews if they asked you about
college you know look at what's going on
in this country right now because they
push college so much you know kids are
in debt just this college debt is so
much but what it also did was it took
kids away from going to trade school my
buddy in Vegas that I grew up with I've
known this kid since the sixth grade
okay
we spoke Friday night I invited him to
the show I left his name on the door
because I thought he would come I think
goes Coco I can't come to your show
because I am so tired because I cannot
find help I go what do you mean because
I'm looking for a mechanic I'm willing
to pay him $45 on how and I cannot find
the mechanic because 45 an hour 45 an
hour but he want to mechanically like
experience one year yes somebody who I
wasn't gonna mechanic school today yeah
no an experienced mechanic because there
was a gap somewhere in society where
everybody was pushed into college and
nobody was pushed into learning trades
yeah and right now the country suffering
because a lot of people aren't there to
fill those gaps
we got a tons of attorneys we got tons
of doctors we got tons of lawyers we got
tons of dentist but we don't have enough
of mechanic
you know and that take I'm not talking
about you going to school and getting
certified in mechanics if you know
anything about my friend his father all
in the gas station on 26th we were
growing up on in Union City on Kennedy
Boulevard so he grew up into in it you
know I'm saying well Mario could fix
anything
but you give Mario that computer he'll
fix it in three days there's people that
have an aptitude for that so they go on
my wife and I were talking about this
dear day how in school when I was
growing up they had an auto body class
yeah do you have I tell ya with the
fixed boys want to be a mechanic no this
small oil change stuff to be honest I
took it for ugh two weeks and I switched
a video class why cuz I wanted to do
video stuff yeah I knew it was gonna be
for me you know they used to be an auto
what's up though you did woodshop yeah
see my wife says that today they don't
have that I'm sure they don't I'm sure
I'm sure they got rid of all are you
serious is the budgets here so my wife
said that they don't teach that anymore
they don't have done curriculums if
anybody's seen that differently please
notify me on Twitter maybe I'm talking
about a place although my wife doesn't
know what she's talking yeah it's uh
exactly what a very rich town
I was the poor kid in rich town and I
think maybe the richer towns might still
have it because they have the budgets
but a lot of most of those kids they
don't want to do that and it's looked
down upon you know in a weird way but in
the end like now that now that you hear
about it like wow I could make 45 an
hour
being a mechanic mechanic that's a lot
of money because the a lot of people
didn't go into that trade you know it's
like a family trade like that the
aptitude listen I got a I got a flat
tire buy a new car you know my tire I
gotta say I'm looking for a new car
because I don't want to change a flat
you know it's not my aptitude
I have zero aptitude for screwdrivers I
could listen if you put a gun to my head
I could cut stuff I can measure stuff I
did it before for years I know how to
install stuff you know if if you put a
gun to my head but is it really what I
want to do for a living no I don't know
I saw people who way better than I did
and had the aptitude yeah I know how to
measure 44 through 66 cut it and put it
up against the wall with sheet rocks or
whatever I know all these roofing and
doing all that I know little things I
know a lot more than I let you onto like
about different things because I haven't
been put in that position in years when
was the last time I had a roofer or do
construction or dig out you know it's
not my world anymore I'm a comic so I
didn't have the aptitude for it it's not
like I said you know we're talking about
this the other day the other night that
at the Las Vegas I had a car for a while
one of those cars he's supposed to work
on like a hobby right and I got rid of
it like I sold them people like you sold
that car you could have made so much
money I just wanted out of my life that
car was for somebody who wants adlai's
wanted to get up and go to the JumpShip
right they were gonna get under a hood
and take the carburetor out of another
Camaro and put it in now you know it
just wasn't for me I knew that I learned
that those cars are for somebody who
they go to the auto parts store every
Saturday and they know I have a
relationship with Bill and you know that
just wasn't me but going back to it that
was why I jumped into at 33 I was like
what the hell am i doing my life if I'm
gonna do something I'm gonna enjoy it
end of story it's not gonna be about cuz
for years you know you have your
guidance counselor what area needs more
what were they saying well they're
saying to get into this you know we do
everything in our lives we let our jobs
control us because yeah obviously we
want the money but at the end of the day
you're gonna find out what makes you
happier is better than that money you
have to be happy doing it before you can
make any money and for years I didn't
believe that
I listen I know a thousand millionaires
today and ever [ __ ] angry about
something I don't know what they're
angry about you know money doesn't buy
you happiness
you know but so don't go for something
that you're going for it if you're a
young kid don't go for it just because
well it's gonna make me money if you
like working on cars tell your mom and
dad this is what I want to do what am I
gonna pay how many kids are unemployed
how much money can we have banks made on
kids on these student loans yeah what
are you gonna do I mean if you could do
it again would you have gone on to
college no yeah it's tough because if
you to get any sort of job you sort of
need a degree but not really
who's came off who's gonna call and
check to see if you went the st. Paul a
minestrone didn't you ever know that
there it is one of people to get caught
now trending is hysterical people
actually call to see if you went to that
college at a certain point it comes out
at a certain point and that's something
I wouldn't want to live with but it's
also I think what you talked about
before I think is a smart move is
there's no reason to jump right from
high school to college I was in a huge
rush I jumped from high school to
college anyone took summer courses and I
graduated in three years instead of four
years that was right I was I wanted to
be out I wanted to be in the in the real
world making money and it's like what I
got I had and I don't now looking back
I'm like what was my rush like I and I
like video stuff but what I've learned
in 12 years being out of high school or
something is that you can't like the
idea that you're gonna plan for your
whole life at 18 is this is new pitous
thing they like its dumbest thing in the
world it's the dumbest thing in the
world even at 25 yeah even at 25 you're
still not gonna know and if you know god
bless you I'm not saying that you're
wrong in the field that you picked god
bless you I'm just sad but how many
people pick a fee
and now they're stuck in that field and
they don't want to do it but this is all
they know yeah you know this you pick a
field and on the field chair and that
happened my cousin my cousin went to
school for film you went to Ithaca a
very good school and two years after he
graduated they switched from film to
digital so his entire entire four-year
degree was gone and now he's a he's
happy but he's a high school principal
now because he had to switch so like I
got something you gotta improvise in
your career - yeah you gotta improvise
and jump I mean you don't know what day
the days in the come I mean I didn't
like I said I didn't know I sit here I'm
going on 29 years on July 18th of me
going onstage the first time and I sit
here baffled people I sit here thinking
what gave me the illusion that I can
ever be a comedian 30 years ago and it
baffles me
it really does baffle me like I'm gonna
come up on a 30th anniversary I couldn't
do anything for 30 days I couldn't stay
sober for 30 days the only thing I did
longer than 30 days was time you know I
mean I think about this stuff for 57 and
I want to just cry like I want to cry
because I can't believe I'm here I
cannot believe I am here and not because
it was a war or not because the people
that know just the whole thing I do not
believe or this seems like a dream like
I'm waiting to get woken up but my
mother to tell me that breakfast is
ready for me to go so Lee was fake yeah
mercy was fake yep Colorado was fake
stand-up was fake yeah you not you
didn't died no you were drunk last night
you just slept 13 hours
like I'm still waiting for my mother to
wake me up from this dream I think about
that a lot sometimes what if I just woke
up and it wasn't real this has to be a
train or all these people that I met it
has to be a dream you know I didn't
believe it in 1982 that my mom was gonna
I thought it was a dream with 2020 I'm
still sitting here going this is just a
bad joke that somebody's playing on
somebody
any minute now some kids gonna kick me
and I'm gonna wake up in that rocket
ship from a hangover and they're gonna
go wake up I'm gonna go where I'm like
you're in North Bergen I'm 88 you would
you think you were North Hollywood
driving to the economy store I'm gonna
go now I thought of it yeah that's
what's gonna happen I'm fearing that
that this is just an all a 12 hours
sleep cuz this couldn't happen
I never saw this coming I never planned
for this I never expected this
at what point like in the last five
years have you started planning for or
like well at what point did this become
a reality or is it still not reality you
know only I'm at home at six o'clock
every night at 6:00 6:30 eating dinner I
listen to my daughter say prayers and
then three two hours later I'm at the
best comedy club in the world telling
dirty jokes talking to the best comics
working today from Bill Bird Marc Maron
to Whitney Cummings to Ali Wong to Tom
Segura and I get my car how do you think
I feel how do you think I feel like I
just you know I could just call Andrew
Dice Clay
I still remember putting renting out the
halfway house to watch Andrew on New
Year's Eve 89 190 or something like that
I still remember renting the doubt
stairs room conference room at the
halfway house to watch Andrew Dice Clay
how can I have Andrew Dice clays number
on my fault how can I just talk to him
and ask him for advice like I do how can
I just call him and ask him for wisdom
like I do I mean are you crazy
this has to be a dream this is a joke
either either this is a joke that
started when when my mother died or this
is a joke we're at 88 and I'm gonna wake
up and I'm gonna go to court this
morning and I'm gonna go wait a sec I
didn't do this already like I didn't do
my time now you've been sleeping since
Friday you you do the three dare of coke
on you and now you Miss Lee that's what
I'm waiting for to be woken up and for
them to say hey come on get up
you running late for Court what are you
talking about you're getting sentenced
this morning now for me to go what about
Whitney Cummings ooh right what about
Joe Rogan who who's Joe Rogan my friend
from Boston the UFC
what's the UFC yeah like like that's
what I'm waiting on any day there yeah
like this so there's not an octagon
where people fight and people yep what
are you talking about
like that's what I'm waiting on what
about the movie Gladiator what are you
talking about Russell Crowe well he
stabbed the guy that that movie come on
what are you talking about you go on a
court in five minutes you running late
that's how I feel guys that's how it
hasn't ever sunken in I think the wife's
just playing a joke I mean I just went
along that now at this point I'm just
going okay yeah I take that episode of
The Twilight Zone when the guy robs the
bank and he's about to jump over the
fence and he gets shot and he lands on
the floor and he and he wakes up and
Sebastian Cabot is dressed in white
faces get up come on let's go before the
cops tell me those who were you
and he goes I'm your guardian angel okay
they takes them back to this hotel and
it takes to the penthouse because you
live here you know and the guys like
what are you talking about I'm a
criminal because you live here this is
your house you know and get get ready
we're going to the ball tonight you know
he goes to this ball and there's all
these hot women he's taking three of
them home a night he's shooting dice and
he's winning at dice and and he comes
home one night and the guy is there and
he tells him like oh my god this place
is great I can't believe you know heaven
it's so great if I would have known this
I would have robbed that Bank 20 years
ago I got shot
this is tremendous I'm never the best
time in my life whoa whoa you're not in
heaven you're in hell that's what I feel
like like one of these days some guys
gonna appear you know I was thinking
about something that happened when I was
a kid about two months before my mom
died
Santeria has like three different
sectors the saints it has the and as his
other sector that I grew up on call it
but he's evil but he did more is the
it's when somebody a certain time in a
month passed the spirit I wasn't too
much into that that was a tough one for
me I mean passing the spirit like the
spirit of pachuco comes into li o on the
third Wednesday of every month okay so
me your father your brother Steve Simone
and Erik a couple chicks we come over
here and once a month you pass that
spirit we'll play some music for you
we'll put some stuff on and all some
will beg to the God to bring this spirit
to pass it through you
and that spirit passes plea and it
speaks to you two people that was the
craziest thing I ever saw in my life
growing up all right but there was one
particular spirit a lady that was a
friend of my mom's that passed this
spirit like once every two months this
stuff and I'm immersing some to me once
talking in maybe sitting there go on I
can't believe these people believe this
[ __ ] you know it was creepy as can be
till this day I don't know right or
wrong for myth it's some I don't like
practicing what's my mom died I never
went to another one of those was a petty
TV more things ever again it's like a
seance Spanish people okay but instead
of with a Ouija board it's like a person
like a spur comes into me and I talked
to people and right before my mom died
I've accumulated lived across the street
from my mom a big fat black Cuban lady
and I murder be called a god that means
fat in Spanish and I'm more Sunday's my
mom would be cooking and she being liver
of watching Yankee games and she could
tell when the lady would take the little
off the pot and dip bread in and eat and
my mom would yell back they're like my
mom had had great hearing and she was
saying or died ha ha ha Frank Eva you
know what I was in the kitchen she would
say there hi I forget what how you call
a pot dances on Aikido you know stop
eating that [ __ ] you know because she
would dip and then she did all the bread
then when the food came she would anyway
once a month that lady passed a spirit
maybe two or three months before my mom
died I got home I'm like why the [ __ ] is
my mom what a [ __ ] is her but that purse
is did everything was there and all that
probably across the street so I want to
cross the street looking for my mom and
sure enough delay these day and she's
got like white powder on her face she's
getting on and she's got like job this
white stuff you put on it's called Katya
its seashell powder but they compact
okay and if they used a lot I used a lot
at home to clean my house like to clean
the front door and on Mondays I use it
but she had it like blown in her face
it was a compact chick with like [ __ ]
dough in the face like you know when a
baker makes them they have that powder
the flour she went she was like I'm
happy you're here your father has a
message for you I was like ah and that's
the last time I talked to that lady and
my mother died I don't know what the
hell happened that lady but the point of
this story is that I still feel like I'm
gonna wake up one day and this is just
all a dream this couldn't have happened
not where I came from not how low in the
position I was in life here's what I
think about that little if it was would
you go for Carmody do you think like if
you woke up with a dream debug alright I
know what I gotta do oh yeah this this
is definitely it you know I mean I'm
talking about all those rooms I did with
Rogen's they didn't happen
all those gigs I did with Duncan and and
you know every time I opened up for Paul
Warren you know that ever happened I
mean meeting Richard Pryor at the store
never happened like none of that
happened Mitzi sure people would say
who's Mitzi sure if it's 1988 people
like yeah I don't think the economy
still came up open till yeah it was open
already it was open but I'm like what
like who like what where would I wake up
at this point I really woke up by going
on going to court that's what I think
like this is just a big jump amen
that's how weird this is for me when I
looked at night at my daughter and my
wife and I know I got a second chance to
be a dad and I got a second chance of
being a human being I can't believe it
that life turned out like this I really
can and I'm happy I'm happy I went for
it I mean listen I'd be depressed if I
woke up in this reserve a dream I'd be
sad if it didn't happen that I'd have to
live to make it happen I have to invent
the Joe Rogan an inventor a Bert
Kreischer an inventor Tom Segura like
but I just don't know I just it's so
surreal for me
let's see let's see what the hell is you
know I guess it's time to go see if you
guys live in your dream I don't know
this has just been a tremendous
experience and I'm talking like if I'm
dying tomorrow I hope I don't die
tomorrow
knock on wood but it's the truth
this has just been and it's not out of
reach anybody could do this you know I
think back what the purpose was of when
you came to me and said hey I think you
should start a podcast and what I always
want all that people know is that there
are no rules there's no rules I'm happy
that I never believed in the rules I'm
happy that I defy authority I'm very
happy I wasn't part of the status quo
I'm very happy that when people told me
what was funny I didn't agree with them
and say that is funny I'm gonna watch
their in week as you watch it I'm very
happy I was the renegade that I was you
know I'm very happy that I didn't listen
to my guidance counselor I'm very happy
that I lived off my instinct you know
your instinct is there use it it's there
for a reason don't be scared of it and
don't double guess it if your instinct
tells you something it's for a reason
that that was put in your heart by God
instinct will save you thousands of
years of misery you know and listen I
put a lot of misery in my life but my
instinct got me I went through thirty
years of misery I could have gone
through fifty if it wasn't for my
instincts Oh trust your instincts you
know that's what they're they had to
tell you this is not good this is good
be honest you know I was always very
honest with myself in the beginning you
know who a laughing table I'm becoming
on with the faith heads
with the cups and you know me having the
girl playing maracas there were just
experiments
and and even if they want an experiment
I took something out of them I took
something out of everything I did I
remember mm after Josh wolf got his deal
I was like I'm gonna get myself a deal
from doing a one-man show and without
rehearsing Italy without nothing I me I
thought that I could write a one-man
show one night oh no oh yeah I got tons
of these I got tons of mistakes stories
how there's no way for me to explain
that to people what's like to write an
hour show in one night
oh you should have thought you should
have seen me I thought I was you know
the guy that wrote the book about Paul's
angels I thought I was like Johnny
author and in my cocaine deranged comedy
I was still green I was a regular at the
store already and stuff I knew the ropes
but for some reason I thought I was
gonna go tell this and then he's this
witty story at the HBO workspace and HBO
was gonna give me a show so what I did
was I took good but again listen to the
story before you call me a [ __ ]
because I call myself a [ __ ]
but I took a sheet of paper and I wrote
a story or wine for The Sopranos I wrote
a story line of who BIG's pussy's
brother is and I forget if I look I
could guarantee I still have it it was a
sheet of paper with a picture on me in
the corner and then the story line of
what was my name I was like Charlie bump
and Sarah I just come out of jail for 12
years I was in a different crew and now
I come back and cause it was like it was
like Jackie of Rio's character nicer
products right I just got out of jail
more to cause traffic so I got my
manager the senator Sopranos to send
them like flyers like I made I got an
HBO workspace in New York wasn't it it
was like East Village or something like
that they had tapes so what they did is
HBO taped everything and then they sent
at HBO and my [ __ ]
Honore ticket creepy mind I figured once
they see the tape I get a call from HBO
so I scheduled this thing I had just
started dating Terry this had to be
either all in September 2000 and I out
nothing this is why her and I got
married it's because of this reason
right there we were dating a month I was
sleeping at Celine in a horse's house
god rest her soul she's the one who
Ralphie stayed with for three months
before
Ralphie moved to LA and then Celine
followed in fact I owe her son my call I
keep meaning to call them and Celine had
a house
Rikki cruise from Miami lived there
Staci booked a little lived there
another friend of ours that lives in
Santa Barbara and I would sleep and
whatever apartment was open in those
days in the building Jody had an
apartment Gavin had an apartment Ralphie
had an apartment and Selena had an
apartment so anybody would Orange entry
at an apartment so anybody who was out
of town it was always some of the other
town that's whose apartment I would
sleep at so the ground flea was out of
town I'd stay in his bed for five days
if Celine was gonna want to work to
shoot I go to stay on her couch for
three days if Gavin left the door open
I'd sleep on his couch or one day you
know was on this particular night I was
staying on Sally's couch Terry had come
home because of those days we have two
County so it was still people up but so
on those days after the comi store - we
went we went out and we would still find
calmly store people around we went to
Celine's house one name we stayed there
my flight was like at 8:30 in the
morning so I figured why go to bed right
so we went back over there analyst party
then everybody went to sleep - me and
Terry stayed alone and we just slept on
the couch like one hour when I got up I
remember that I had somebody was giving
me a ride to the airport already they
were going to the airport or something
right
but I'm a material me do you have money
and I basically we had like maybe $18
and like two joints on like eight
cigarettes and I was going to New York
and I would get taken care of once I was
in New York I had friends that would
give me money and but she asked me if I
had money and I was like no and she gave
me up whatever money she made that night
waitressing
she gave me plus she gave me her
cigarettes and she said she had change
at the house and that she was going to
go to work right to work anyways and she
was gonna sleep all day they call her
when I get to New York I never forgot
that gesture that she did she gave me
every dollar she had every dollar she
gave me the whole thing in a wallet $66
42 whatever the [ __ ] it was and she gave
me a cigarettes and because of that it's
the reason why we're married today
Wow because I never forgot that gesture
that gesture you know this is a town
where you tell girl you broke they leave
you yeah you know you tell a girl you
broken this time they leave you she
raised she put a hand out so nine years
later I said to myself how can I not
marry this woman
but anyway it's Monday the 2nd of March
and you got yourself a whole new church
episode on a Monday morning and that's
it and that's that I'm happy you guys
listen today I don't know what the hell
we talked about for the last hour
I hope it's interesting and I hope it
gets you going on a Monday morning
do not forget Thursday the 12th of March
I am at levity live in Nyack New York
with my man and June on diao sitting in
the front row what else do I have in
March I got March 27th at Arlington
theater and Santa Barbara California
just two little dates because I'm
finishing up from shooting in New York
and so I just got two little day three
this month so I got May 12th at Miami
March March 12th at levity live and
March 27
than theologians Theatre and Santa
Barbara California before we go I want
to mention our sponsors number one
manscape
listen spring is coming and you want it
to feel like like it's spring break 1988
you got to get mad skates why because
the engineers at manscaping have spent
the last 18 months crafting the perfect
ball head trimmer for you you likes joy
what I gotta trim my balls why cuz it
looks like a bear and it smells that's
why and they just released a new and
improved lawn mower 3.0 smooth out that
scrotum with the new ceramic blade and
manscaped
advanced skin safe technology listen for
you mow mows in the back
this means it won't stick or snag your
nutsack no blood no more anxiety no
nothing you've seen the videos of me
shaving I just pulled my little dipstick
you protect that stick of debt and you
just shave around that and then you pick
up that stick of death and pick up your
nutsack and shave under that voila right
now it looks like baby's little balls
it's that smooth nice and smooth the
lawnmower 3.0 has a lot of upgraded
features with making it the best razor
system you've ever owned it's got an LED
light so you can get into all those
nooks and crannies and if you want to
shave at night in the dark whatever
turns you on
they also juiced up this baby with 7000
RPM motor with the quiet stroke
technology so no one can hear you but
yourself the battery now lasts up to 90
minutes and the charging stand is
powered by UCSB this couldn't be an
easier time easier way to use if you
have the manscape 2.0 razor it's easy
now you can use the same replacement
blades in the 3.0 and you can upgrade it
yourself so do me a favor get 20% off
and free shipping when you go to
manscape comm slash church again 20% off
and free shipping when you go to
manscape comm they're doing you the
favor of the world why because you're
sitting there nothing happens in my life
it all starts with a clean nutsack baby
and a clean dips
take if you got everything shaved and
look as smooth forget about it the
damage you'll do you start lifting you
take some alpha brain some shroom
technique walk then sling some dick you
can't lose
but it all starts to manscape so do me a
favor get 20% off from free shipping
when you go to the manscape comm slash
church again that's manscape comm slash
church for 20% off your first daughter
gets man skates and get laid I want to
thank manscape but most importantly I
want to thank you guys for always having
our back and listening this is the first
Monday of the month podcast we always
just do us and just do a very informal
one just to let you know we love you and
we still care about you
do not forget March 12th Nyack New York
and March 27 up there in Santa Barbara
beautiful city and that's it and that's
that have a great day
we'll be back Wednesday stay black and
have a great week
kick this mule Lisa